c'est bonjour quelles sont les mots
d'ordre de la manifestation aujourd'hui
est bien toujours aller même que deux
pions samedis consécutifs maintenant la
neige non au pass sanitaires non à
l'obligation vaccinale pour certaines
professions et puis surtout nom propre à
sanitaires pour aller 12 à 17 ans une
extension à de cette mesure qui entrera
en vigueur le 30 septembre prochain et
bien évidemment les gilet jaune ils sont
opposés je vous propose de les écouter
de madame d'aujourd'hui je parle parfois
me taire je suis pas pour lui que
comporte le match est une chose mais
nous nous obliger à voir à pas de
sanitaires
une atteinte à la liberté je veux
pouvoir aller comme avant par la vie
d'avant enfin qui ne reviendra jamais je
veux pas être surveillés je veux pas
être avec du crédit social comme en
chine on a des droits faut qu'on les
respecte les gouvernements toute façon
ils sont tous pourris de droite comme de
gauche ici on est tous contre le passage
du ter n'est pas contre la vaccination
on est juste là pour montrer aux gens
pour montrer au gouvernement que eux ils
s'entêtent mais nous on les suit on cela
on et leurs réponses ils ne veulent pas
entendre la rue balard eut fait encore
plus de bruit la rue va continuer à
faire du bruit jusqu'à ce que mc ont
quitté disaient
aller au delà de s'opposer aux mesures
sanitaires mises en place par le
gouvernement allait gilet jaune réclame
toujours à plus de justice sociale plus
de justice fiscale plus de démocratie
participative au cices à qui nous avons
à parler c'est ce qu'ils nous ont confié
ils entendent montrer donc ils sont
toujours mobilisés du côté du corps tête
du cortège vous l'avez dit un adage il
devrait elle s'est lancée d'ici quelques
minutes or en direction du sacré coeur
merci pour cette précision est el farj
on vous retrouvera tout au long de cet
après midi pour suivre cette
manifestation